[Musik]
schönen guten Abend hier bei Bild ein
Krieg ja der sich über ein ganzes Jahr
gestreckt hat der endet jetzt
zehntausende Tote Millionen Flüchtlinge
und bei uns ein teuer Schock der unseren
Wohlstand bedroht und wo ist jetzt der
Ausweg aus Putins Angriffskrieg wie
endet der darüber spreche ich jetzt hier
im Studio bei Bild mit Franz Alter ja
ein Pazifist ist darf ich sagen und der
die Zweite Weltkrieg als Kind noch
erlebt habe als kleines Kind als
heranwachsendes Kind haben sie
Erinnerungen Herr alt an diese Zeit an
ein Weihnachten im Krieg
wenn man 1938 geboren ist hat man
natürlich Erinnerungen und einen zweiten
Weltkrieg vor allen Dingen erinnere ich
mich dass mein Vater aus dem Krieg
heinkam und über Weihnachten einige Tage
bei uns war das ist unvergesslich aber
auch andererseits
dass mir die Kugeln um die Ohren flogen
und unser Haus zweimal zerstört war im
badischen Untergrombach meine Heimat und
meiner Mutter hat eine Kugel sogar am
Ohr getroffen also
wenige Zentimeter daneben und sie wäre
tot gewesen das sind schreckliche
Erinnerungen deshalb nicht vielleicht
nicht zuletzt deshalb bin ich Pazifist
geworden allerdings ich war auch mal ein
scharfamilitarrist mit fünf Jahren
erinner ich mich und die
älteren Menschen in meiner Heimat
ebenfalls bin ich hinter einer
Beerdigung nachgezogen mit einem
wirklichen ein Freund hat es gezogen und
wir haben beide gesungen siegreich
wollen wir Frankreich schlagen und ich
musste in der ersten Klasse noch den
Hitlergruß machen und habe ihn gemacht
das war also 1953 ganz ganz ganz lange
her sie sind dann ein Jugendlicher sie
haben ein Leben gelebt im Wohlstand in
Deutschland und vor allen Dingen in
Friedenszeiten hier in Europa ist das
für uns alle für auch ihre Generation
eine Niederlage empfinden sie das so
dass man jetzt so viele Jahrzente später
wieder ein Krieg hat in Europa und so
direkt vor der Haustür
vor allen Dingen nach der friedlichen
Wiedervereinigung habe ich mir so etwas
wie wir jetzt in der Ukraine erleben
nicht mehr vorstellen können vielleicht
auch nicht mehr vorstellen wollen Helmut
Schmidt hat immer gesagt alles kann sich
wiederholen er hatte leider recht alles
auch Kriege insofern denke ich wir haben
noch eine große lern als Menschheit eine
große Lernaufgabe vor uns und zwar als
gesamte Menschheit nicht nur Putin also
den Atomkrieg bereiten wir genauso vor
wie die andere Seite leider haben wir
einen neuen atomkriegsmächte das ist für
mich die größte Gefahr aber empfinden
sie darf ich noch mal fragen auch ein
bisschen sie haben das ja nur bei Gott
nicht zu verantworten aber es ist auch
gerade diese Generation die so lange
eben im Frieden gelebt hat und jetzt ein
alter Mann in Russland der diesen Krieg
anzetteln erfinden sie das ein bisschen
als die Niederlage auch dieser
Generation die Kriege gekannt hat und
jetzt wieder Krieg führt also Krieg ist
immer eine Niederlage für die gesamte
Menschheit etwas schlimmeres als Krieg
gibt es nicht Krieg ist nie die Lösung
Krieg ist immer die Krankheit und
insofern finde ich das als ganz
furchtbar das so etwas wie der kam ich
finde ich kann niemand einen Vorwurf
machen wenn er wie ich an den ewigen
Frieden geglaubt hat zumindest in Europa
ich dachte immer naja in anderen Ländern
auf anderen Kontinenten wo es viele
soziale Probleme gibt wo es auch
ressourcenprobleme gibt zwischen den
reichen Industriestaaten und den
ölfördernden Ländern zum Beispiel Irak
ist so ein Beispiel
mein Buch damals hieß kriegen Öl oder
Frieden durch die Sonne also wir haben
immer Alternativen auch jetzt gibt es
Alternativen ich bin ganz sicher diese
Kriege irgendwann zu Ende gehen wir
gleich ja ganz kurz zurück sie haben
gesagt sie haben selber nicht daran
glauben wollen dass es noch mal Krieg
geben könnte war das ein Stück weit auch
von ihnen naiv ja das war sicherlich zu
naiv Angela Merkel hat mich vor Jahren
schon erzählt Putin lügt sie ständig an
auch sie hat es schwer gehabt mit ihm
klarzukommen aber sie hat gesagt ich
muss es versuchen mehr sie hat sich
selber anlügen lassen muss man jetzt
Jahre später sagen ja aber sie hat auch
es gewusst dass er sie anlügt und sie
hat vielleicht auch Illusionen gehabt
über Putin Gorbatschow hat mir aber
gesagt der war bei Angela Merkel im
Kanzleramt eingeladen und hat sie ihr
gesagt sie müssen den Draht zu Putin
halten hat sie gesagt
er lügt mich aber an es ist schwer
Körperschaft hat gesagt ich weiß aber
man hat es trotzdem die Alternative wäre
Krieg haben sie mit ihr danach nach der
Kanzlerschaft noch mal genau darüber
sprechen können da kannst du schaffen
nicht mehr aber vorher haben uns einige
Male getroffen und ich weiß dass auch
sie die Vorstellung hatte man kann mit
Putin Geschäfte machen übrigens die
ganze deutsche Wirtschaft also es war
nicht nur die Kanzlerin die in diesem
Fall etwas naiv war und ich auch sondern
es war die ganze deutsche Wirtschaft es
hat wieder mal das die entscheidende
Rolle das Geld gespielt geld regiert die
Welt auch in Deutschland
bei der Fußballweltmeister hat sie man
ist natürlich nachher schlauer aber hat
sie einen ganz entscheidenden Fehler
gemacht Angela Merkel ich glaube sie
hätte früher auf die Energiewende
darüber haben wir oft diskutiert und
Kanzleramt auch ersetzen sollen und den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
forcieren müssen so dass wir weniger
Abhängigkeit gehabt hätten von Putins
Gas und Öl wie würden Sie jetzt am Ende
dieses Jahres eines Jahres voller Krieg
unser aller Gemütszustand hier in
Deutschland gerade beschreiben depressiv
kriegen sie am Anfang gesagt haben so
ähnlich empfinde ich es auch depressiv
Depressionen helfen nicht das habe ich
mal nach einer Therapie mühsam lernen
wir sind Depressionen helfen
niemanden also die Realitäten sehen und
wissen es gibt immer Alternativen nehmen
Sie mal der heutigen Tag die heutigen
Meldungen wir haben einen wunderbaren
Erfolg bei der Welt naturkonferenz
erlebt zum ersten Mal haben sich 200
Staaten darauf geeinigt die Arten mehr
zu schützen und besser zu schützen und
30% der Erde und der Meere unter
Naturschutz zu stehen als das bisher da
war das gibt mir Mut das zeigt es gibt
immer auch Fortschritte also ein großes
Thema für mich und für Sie und oder für
alle die uns jetzt zuschauen was
sicherlich die deutsche Einheit das
hätte auch ein Vierteljahr zuvor nicht
für möglich gehalten Bärbel Bolle ich
hatte mich eingeladen in ihrer Wohnung
zur Gründung des Neuen Forums in der
Fehrbelliner Straße 91 werde ich nie
vergessen das Hassel 28 Menschen die
vorher noch kurz zuvor im Gefängnis
waren und haben gesagt wir machen das
neue Forum und haben gesagt wir schaffen
das für mich das politische Wunder
schlechthin es ist so schön bisschen
Optimismus zu hören aber Millionen
Deutschen geht's in diesen Tagen
natürlich völlig anders und gerade in
der Weihnachtszeit ja wir sind Mann sich
noch mal man sucht vielleicht auch das
hoffnungsvolle das optimistische und man
findet gerade so wenig weil man den
Eindruck hat es ist in diesem Jahr alles
alles schlechter geworden
schauen Sie mal
vor drei Jahren hätte niemand gedacht
dass ein Film damals 15-jähriges
schwedisches Mädchen eine Weltbewegung
organisiert zugunsten des Klimas Kreta
in Stockholm
das ist ein politisches Wunder
zu deutschen Einheit hat das Spiegel
geschrieben ein politisches Wunder es
war kein Wunder es war der Wille der
deutschen der ostdeutschen vor allem die
ihre Angst abgelegt hatten und gesagt
haben wir sind das Volk in Russland
demonstrieren zur Zeit fast täglich
viele Menschen vor allen Dingen die
Mütter der potentiellen Soldaten braucht
und sagen unsere Kinder werdet ihr nicht
wir opfern euch nicht unsere Kinder aber
ein Wunder zu glauben das fällt so
wahnsinnig schwer wenn man im Moment die
Stromrechnung auf dem Tisch bekommt vor
allen Dingen die Gasrechnung auf dem
Tisch bekommt wenn man sieht wie Firmen
pleite gehen wie wenig auch bisher
offenbar die Sanktionen und die
Waffenlieferung helfen das heißt
im Moment ist das Gefühl wir kommen da
gar nicht raus in solchen Zeiten ist es
umso wichtiger dass man sich daran
erinnert dass es auch immer positive
Entwicklungen gab also es ist nicht das
erste Mal dass es in Krieg gibt die
Kriege die weit weg sind haben wir gerne
übersehen und auch zum Teil verdrängt
also der Krieg im Jemen zum Beispiel der
Krieg in Äther bürgerlich in Äthiopien
da haben vor vier Wochen die beiden
Kriegsgegner die Zentralregierung und
die Regierung im Norden Äthiopiens einen
Friedensvertrag geschlossen sie haben 14
Tage miteinander gerungen haben sich
plötzlich als Brüder angeredet und haben
einen Waffenstillstand und einen
Friedensvertrag hingekriegt in Kolumbien
war jahrzehntelang Bürgerkrieg mit nicht
zuletzt mit Vermittlung des Papstes
franziskus ist es gelungen und der
Kirche der katholischen Kirche in
Kolumbien eine Friedensvertrag zu
organisieren auch der Krieg in der
Ukraine wird irgendwann zu Ende sein je
mehr Menschen darauf vertrauen dass wir
nicht
zum Krieg führen auf der Welt sind
sondern letztlich zum Frieden schaffen
kann würde sagen zum ewigen Frieden ich
würde das so wahnsinnig gerne ich würde
so wahnsinnig gerne auch mit Ihnen hier
heute abend daran glauben und trotzdem
bin ich mit dem Blick auf 2023 deutlich
pessimistischer auch was die Lage hier
in Deutschland angeht besorgt sie das
gar nicht dass es immer mehr Armut geht
dass das ist Menschen gibt die bisher
sich eigentlich keine Sorge machen
mussten um mir auskommen und plötzlich
wegen der hohen Energiepreise Abstürzen
ihr Leben nicht mehr finanzieren können
Michael Gorbatschow hat mir kurz vor
seinem Tod noch mal ein E-Mail geschickt
mit einem Aufsatz den er geschrieben hat
in einer wissenschaftlichen Zeitungen
Russland und hat gesagt die Menschheit
hat drei große Aufgaben und sie sind
lösbar erstens wir müssen eine
atomwaffenfreie Welt hinbekommen davon
sind wir weiter entfernt davon sind wir
weit entfernt wenn ich nach Nordkorea
gucke aber auch im Westen wir haben alle
Atombomben sind bis zur Halskrause mit
Atombomben eingedeckt wir können uns
mindestens 20 mal umbringen noch immer
gegenseitig aber wir müssen daran
arbeiten es gibt immer Alternativen
Gorbatschow hat's vorgemacht Gorbatschow
hat mit einem kalten Krieger namens
Hecken
eine Abrüstung die größte Abrüstung der
Welt zustande gebracht ich habe mal
gefragt wie haben Sie das geschafft dann
sagt er ich habe zu diesem Menschen der
mich als Ausgeburt des Bösen Reiches
bösen bezeichnet hat ein Vertrauen
aufgebaut und habe ich ihn nachgefragt
in einer Fernsehsendung wo haben sie die
Kraft hergenommen und dann sagte er die
Kraft steht hinter der Kamera und hat
auf seine Frau Isa gedeutet und die hat
zurückgewunken weil das Vertrauen im
Moment wunderbar wir sprechen vor der
politischer Wunder neben den
riesenproblemen die es gibt wir sprechen
und ich komme gleich noch mal auf die
Energiepreise zu sprechen der alte auch
wenn Sie bisher den Weg gegangen sind
immer dann ganz optimistisch davon
wegzugehen dann sprechen wir über
vertrauen wie soll das denn entstehen
zwischen silenski und Putin zwischen
Putin und beiden oder zwischen Putin und
Scholz sie haben selber gesagt der hat
die ganze Welt der hat alle
Regierungschefs belogen wie soll denn
Vertrauen entstehen das ist schwierig
ich habe kein Patentrezept aber ich habe
einige Beispiele auch ich bin auch
Historiker einige Beispiele aus der
Geschichte die deutlich machen dass das
geht und wie würden Sie denn anfangen
mit ihm
indem ich im Sinne der Bergpredigt was
meine
beste Überzeugung ist dass uns Jesus
auch hier Angebote gemacht hat
auf die Feindesliebe ein Schlüsselwort
von Jesus verweisen das heißt nur nicht
dass ich Putin leben muss
Feindesliebe ist für mich in erster
Linie
das Verständnis mich in den anderen
hineinzuversetzen hat er das verdient
dieses Verständnis helmut Kohl hat
gesagt er hat es verdient helmut Kohl
hat kurz vor seinem Tod noch mal gesagt
in einem Interview ähnlich wie Helmut
Schmidt wir haben es sich die NATO wir
der Westen haben die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands viel zu
wenig beachtet Kohl und Helmut Schmidt
haben das gesagt also man kann die Welt
nicht einteilen wie wir das oft tun dort
die hier die hier die Juden und auf der
anderen Seite immer die müssen den Bösen
in Angebot ja auch machen sie müssen
sich reinsetzen und was steht da drauf
auf dem Angebot weil dann wird es ja
heikel bei der Frage richtig was
bedeutet ja ab jetzt hier am Tisch
würden wir mal locker ein paar Regionen
von der Ukraine Herz überhaupt nicht
nein überhaupt nicht sondern das müssen
erstens das müssen die Ukraine selber
entscheiden das ist Sache der Ukraine
zweitens aber das ist jetzt unser
Problem
Sicherheit kann spätestens jetzt im
Atomzeitalter immer nur wirklich
Sicherheit sein wenn sie auch die
Sicherheit des anderen ist und da hat
der Westen große Fehler gemacht 1990
hatte die NATO 16 Mitglieder jetzt haben
wir 30 Herr weißer stellen sich mal
einen Augenblick vor Kanada im Norden
der USA oder Mexiko im Süden der USA
werden und sagen werden sagen und
beschließen politisch wir schließen uns
einen Militärbündnis von Russland an na
die Natur war ein Verteidigungsbündnis
und Putin führt einen angriffskrieger
also
tatsächlich bedroht fühlte das ist noch
als Beweisführung bisher nicht gelungen
dass es seine Argumentation der alten
Glauben Argumentation und ich fürchte
dass da viel viel dran ist mir mal
erklärt wie Putin sozialisiert wurde er
hat gesagt dieser Typ
ist im Hinterhof von St Petersburg
aufgewachsen und hat immer gesagt auch
geschrieben ich kann nur nach oben
kommen wenn ich draufschlagen und so wie
wir sozialisiert worden sind machen wir
auch Politik oder für diesen Krieg aus
Angst glauben sie aus Bedrohung ist viel
Angst dabei ja klar also jeder
Psychotherapeut kann das nachempfinden
und ich glaube wir sind einfach zu wenig
in der Lage bisher uns in andere hinein
zu versetzen das erste ist jetzt dass
wir dafür sorgen dass auch die
ukraine-sicherheitszusagen bekommt von
Russland aber auch die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands müssen
wir eher mit Bedenken als wir das bisher
gemacht haben das heißt sie müssten ihm
wenn man ihre Argumentation jetzt folgt
die Angst nehmen
Putin die Angst ich muss mit dafür
sorgen dass ich seine Sicherheit ernst
nehme und dadurch seine Angst abbaue wir
können doch nicht so weitermachen wie
bisher unsere eigene Angst dadurch
überwinden dass wir anderen noch mehr
Angst machen das ist die Situation im
Atomzeitalter wenn du mich 25 mal
vernichten kannst muss ich dafür sorgen
dass ich dich 30 Mal vernichten kann das
muss in die Katastrophe führen deshalb
hat schon völlig recht wenn er kurz vor
seinem Tod uns noch mal daran erinnert
hat dass das wichtigste für den Frieden
und die Sicherheit in der Welt ist dass
wir einen übereinstimmenden
kontrollierbaren Vertrag hinkriegen in
dem die Welt auf einem Weg zur atomaren
Abrüstung ist jetzt schauen wir auf
dieses Jahr und auf die deutsche
Außenpolitik auf Sanktionen auf
Waffenlieferung sehen Sie einen Erfolg
davon
zumindest ist die Ukraine nicht
ausgelöscht worden wie es Putin wollte
zumindest haben auch deutsche
Waffenlieferungen das fällt mir nicht
leicht das Pazifist zu sagen aber es ist
so dass ich der Realität dazu
beigetragen das ukrainische Leben
gerettet wird
das ist wirklich nachvollziehbar ich
habe viele Fernsehberichte gesehen die
deutlich gemacht haben deutsche
Raketenabwehr hat mitgeholfen dass die
russische Raketen abgeschossen haben
aber dann wäre es doch logisch zu sagen
wir schicken mehr wir schicken das
Doppelte wir versuchen ihn zu bezwingen
wir versuchen die russischen Truppen
zurückzudrängen aus dem ukrainischen
Gebiet ja das machen wir ja
wahrscheinlich mehr als wir Journalisten
angenommen haben
Kanzler Scholz hat in dieser Woche vor
einigen Tagen in der Süddeutschen
Zeitungen und Ganzheit die Interview
gesagt dass wir weiterhin die Ukraine
unterstützen wollen ab einem bestimmten
Punkt ist es mit bestimmten
Waffenlieferung sicherlich zu Ende was
ich gut nachvollziehen kann Scholz der
sicherlich zögert und zaudert da bin ich
der Opposition Recht geben aber mir ist
ein bei Waffenlieferungen ein bei
Waffenlieferungen zögern da und zaubern
der Bundeskanzler lieber als ein
Draufgänger
jetzt versuchen wir rauszufinden wie wir
alle ganz gemeinsam und vor allen Dingen
die Ukraine aus diesem Krieg rausfinden
kann also ist es eine Option endet ein
Krieg dadurch dass in diesem Fall die
russische Armee besiegt werden kann
schauen Sie mal
trotz dieser furchtbaren Kriegssituation
ist es den Russen und den Ukrainern oder
der Vermittlung der UNO gelungen ein
weizenabkommen zu schließen
trotz dieses furchtbaren Krieges ist es
beiden Seiten gelungen mit Hilfe der UNO
wieder Gefangene auszutauschen warum
soll es nicht möglich sein
keiner weiß den Zeitpunkt ich auch nicht
und der Bundeskanzler hat keine weiß es
auch nicht wir müssen den Kontakt halten
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass er
Interesse hat und ihm natürlich auch
gewisse Sicherheitsgarantien geben dass
wir die NATO nicht weiter ausdehnen dass
Ukraine nicht von heute auf morgen in
die Natur aufgenommen hat obwohl jedes
Volk das Recht hat eine militärbnis
einem abwehrbündnis das ist die Natur in
der Tat beizutreten trotzdem braucht
auch Putin Sicherheitsinteressen ich
wissen Sie zu Beginn des Krieges hat er
russische Geheimdienst festgestellt
waren 80% der Russen hinter Protein
jetzt sind es noch 20% auch Putin
regiert nicht ewig jede Diktatur hat ein
Ende auch die putinische dikt aber das
heißt ja dann doch wieder dass der Weg
funktioniert also dass der Krieg für ihn
auch extrem teuer wird endet weil er für
eine der beiden Seiten zu teuer wird
also ich bin da nicht der Fachmann dazu
nur heute habe ich wieder gelesen dass
die russische Wirtschaft zwar noch nicht
zusammenbricht aber immer größere
Probleme bekommt durch den Krieg ich
glaube über 50% des etas in Russland
wird jetzt fürs Militär ausgegeben das
wird ein Volk wie die Russen sich auf
Dauer nicht bieten lassen zu teuer kann
ja auch sein dass man immer mehr der
eigenen Söhne und Väter ist Gott
beerdigen muss wahrscheinlich sind die
größten Feinde für Putin
die Mütter der Soldaten
das sagen sie auch mit ihrer
zweitweltkriegserfahrung richtig ja auch
meine Mutter war gegen den Krieg und kam
beinahe zu Tode und ich bin ganz sicher
alle Mütter der Welt wollen nicht ihre
Söhne als militärisches
Opfer darbringen haben sie in all diesen
Monaten eigentlich verstanden was unsere
Position unsere deutsche Position da ist
was wir eigentlich uns wünschen was
unsere Regierung will in diesem Krieg
natürlich Frieden ich kenne in
Deutschland wirklich niemand der sagt
der der Krieg ist in Ordnung ich kenne
nur Friedens Menschen allerdings müssen
wir jetzt bitte es war Einschneiden der
vor einem verantwortungsvollen und vor
einem verantwortungslosen Pazifismus
gewarnt hat ich sage in diesem Buch real
Pazifismus das ist meine Position ich
muss als Pazifist leider auch jetzt für
deutsche Waffenlieferung sein weil sie
wirklich helfen Menschen leben zu retten
aber die Deutschen haben haben so etwas
wie ein pazifistisches gehen ich war
ziemlich erschrocken als unsere
Verteidigungsministerin vor einigen
Wochen gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt den
deutschen den Pazifismus austreiben
bitte Frau Verteidigungsministerin nicht
den Pazifismus austreiben wir müssen mit
dafür sorgen dass mehr Frieden in der
Welt passiert und dass sie wenigstens
bequem in vielen Momenten ist das bequem
aus unserer deutschen Sicht dass man
sich eben nicht engagiert dass man nicht
unterstützt also wir engagieren uns ja
also Pazifismus heißt für mich auch für
ukrainische Flüchtlinge aufnehmen und
versorgen wir sind in Berlin hier wird
vorgemacht dass das geht bei einer
Million kam zu uns und wir werden
weiterhin helfen müssen ich fürchte in
diesem Winter wenn er noch mehr helfen
müssen das ist ja furchtbar wie Putin
die Infrastruktur zerstört er will mit
er nimmt Millionen Tote in Kauf die
erfrieren die verhungern die verdursten
das ist eine der furchtbarsten
Katastrophen wie gesagt für nicht mehr
vorstellbar gewesen aber es ist leider
so ich muss von Realitäten ausgehen ich
frage deswegen nach dem bisschen böse
nach dem bequemen Pazifismus weil es an
diesem Tisch so wahnsinnig leicht fällt
sich Frieden zu wünschen und weil man
dann dort in Kiew vor der inhakife oder
in mariopol ein ganz anderen Eindruck
von der Situation
fundamentalistischen Pazifisten mein
gebe ich Ihnen Recht das kann ein
bequemer Weg sein wenn Sie meinen dass
manche Pazifisten in Deutschland zu
wenig anders Leid der Betroffenen Denken
in der Ukraine geben Ihnen auch recht
aber als real Pazifist bin ich für
Waffenlieferung und für möglichst viele
humanitäre Hilfe hätten sie gerne als
Pazifistin eine Außenministerin
ja ich finde die macht eine
real-pazifistische Außenpolitik sie ist
auch für Waffenlieferungen aber sagt
zugleich müssen wir alle Möglichkeiten
nutzen um Putin an den Verhandlung
natürlich
Frau bärburg will doch aber mehr
Waffenlieferung das ist für sie
Pazifismus das ist real,-
sie hat ja in diesen Tagen auch gesagt
deutsche abwehrwaffen retten
ukrainisches Leben da bin ich bei ihr
und wenn es noch mehr werden muss unter
Umständen ja aber es muss immer geprüft
werden dass wir nicht eigene
Kriegspartei werden also die Grünen die
ja ganz starke pazifistische Strömungen
ihrer Partei immer hatten die machen
jetzt dort indem sie auch
Waffenlieferung massiv befördern aus
ihrer Sicht aus der Sicht von Franz
alten guten Job machen Realpolitik und
das ist Pragmatismus das ist das ist
Politik ja aber dann noch mal konkret
was haben sie erreicht denn
in diesem Jahr ist nicht die Situation
am Ende dieses Jahres verfahrener
verstockter denn je
das weiß ich nicht ob sie noch
verstockter ist also bisher schon die
ganze Zeit war vielleicht wird sie neu
2023 noch verstockter also man muss das
Schlimmste befürchten nach dem nachdem
wir jetzt sehen wie Putin sich benimmt
und wie ist wie schwer ist ist in
anderen verhandlungssicht zu bringen
bitte Scholz hat versucht macron hat
versucht
15 Meter auseinander an dem Tisch und
sogar über die 15 Meter reicht es immer
um sich zu belügen dieses Bild war sehr
typisch es reichte um die ganze
westliche Welt zu belügen und nicht nur
er auch sein Außenminister und sein
Kriegsminister sind wirklich ein Lügner
neben dem anderen es ist schwierig aber
wir haben schon oft schwieriges
Situationen wenn man so alt ist wie ich
kennt man die Geschichte des Kalten
Krieges sehr sehr gut und wir standen
noch am Abgrund und haben es trotzdem
geschafft dank eines politischen Wunders
wie Gorbatschow das war die größte
Abrüstung der Geschichte der zweiten
Hälfte 80 vorne in den 90ern hingebracht
haben kontrollierte Abrüstung dass wir
jetzt wieder notwendig viele Sagen in
der Verzweiflung eben weil man am Ende
dieses Jahres sagt Mensch nach so viel
hunderten Tagen Krieg nach 10.000 Toten
nach Hunderttausenden Flüchtlingen
Millionen Flüchtlingen mittlerweile ist
die Situation so verfahren dass
eigentlich nur eines hilft Tyrannenmord
ich weiß nicht ob tiranen Modell helfen
würde ich verstehe Staufenberg aber ob
Tyrannenmord helfen würde es wäre
wahrscheinlich ein zweiter Hitler
gekommen oder sehr wahrscheinlich in
zweiter Hitler gekommen ob ein zweiter
Putin oder aus Tschetschenien noch ein
schlimmerer Erfolg ist eine offene Frage
deshalb ich sage ich verstehe Tyrannen
Mord aber ich bin nicht für Tyrannen
Mord solange es irgend geht und Putin
hat ja auch ein paar Zeichen gegeben in
diesen Tagen dass er bereit wäre zu
verhandeln und schiebt im selenski denn
die den den schwarzen Peter zu dass er
im Moment nicht verhandeln will was ich
auch wieder verstehe aber silenski
wollte am Anfang des Krieges verhandeln
war bereits sogar über die Krim zu
verhandeln über den dombas und Putin
wollte nicht jetzt ist es umgekehrt also
es bewegt sich einiges und es gibt
einige Signale das ganze ist ja mehr als
ein Krieg zwischen zwei Nachbarn das
ganze hat auch eine globale Dimension
und das lässt mich hoffen dass
wenn die Zeichen die aus Washington
kommen deutlicher werden Putin
vielleicht doch bereit ist mit beiden
über eine Lösung des schrecklichen
Konflikts zu reden und auch beiden dazu
bereit ist
die USA genügend tut um genau das also
mehr als Norddeutschland hilft sehr aber
materiell und finanziell noch mehr
materiell Finanz und auch militärisch
noch mehr als wir und Sie haben ja auch
mehr Möglichkeiten als wir wenn man
einen heutigen Tag hängt mit dem
deutschen Panzern also ähm ich hoffe
dass beiden es schafft Putin an dich zu
bringen das wäre für Putin schon die
Tatsache dass beiden in anregt zu
verhandeln ein Imagegewinn und den
sollte man den wirklich können noch mal
zurück zu diesem Wort Tyrannen Mord sie
haben gerade lange überlegt haben sie
sich in den vergangenen Monaten mal
ertappt bei dem Gedanken und dabei ganz
kurz eine Sympathie für diesen Gedanken
empfohlen also eine unserer Töchter hat
ich meine das sei doch eine Lösung und
ich habe heftigst widersprochen und
gesagt also
ich bin nicht wenn ich sicher wäre
würde ich darüber nachdenken dass er
eine bessere Lösung kommt nach Putin in
der nachtpotenzeit aber da kann man
nicht sicher sein ich weiß nicht mehr
genau der Namen des Tschetschenen
Führers der da immer die oft
der immer gesagt hat Putin ist nicht
konsequent genug man musste viel mehr
drauf schlagen noch also es ist nicht
auszuschließen da so ein Typ dann der
Nachfolger wäre und das wäre nicht
leichter das wäre noch schwieriger ja
jetzt stehen wir kurz vor Weihnachten
paar Tage noch ist die Erkenntnis dieses
Jahres einer Erkenntnis dieses Jahres
das Waffen mehr helfen als zu beten
ich erinnere mich an das Ende des Kalten
Krieges in Leipzig der ersten
Demonstrationen ich glaube am 9 Oktober
nach der großen Demonstration wo die
Demonstranten 10.000 Fach riefen keine
Gewalt hat der damalige Stasi-Chef von
Leipzig seine zentrale verlassen um
Mitternacht und gesagt wir alle haben
mit allem gerechnet nur nicht mit
Gebeten und mit Kerzen das politische
Wunder ist geschehen ich glaube auf
geistige Ebene passiert viel viel mehr
als wir Heutigen Materialisten und so
gerne vorher aber dort doch das
Gegenteil die Patriarchen von Moskau und
in der Ukraine die Geistlichen ähnlich
die sind voll für den Krieg für mich ist
das in dieser Zeit als Christ ist dass
die eigentliche also die Katastrophe
hinter der Katastrophe dieser patria ich
aus Moskau der vom heiligen Krieg fast
das ist das Gegenteil
ja ja ja
und den Putin unterstützt ist das
Gegenteil dessen was Jesus in seiner
Bergpredigt gemeint hat Frieden heißt
friedenschaffenheit und Feindesliebe
versetzt dich in die Situation des
Gegners habe den Mut zum ersten Schritt
denk mal darüber nach dass Sicherheit
auch seine Sicherheit ist das wäre für
mich Bergpredigt aber der Patriarch von
Moskau macht leider das Gegenteil eine
reine Katastrophe
wir stehen jetzt kurz davor vor dem
Jahreswechsel und Sie haben gerade ihre
Kinder angesprochen Enkel angesprochen
mit den wir über all diese Themen
sprechen und sprechen müssen immer
wieder sie werden versuchen Optimismus
zu verbreiten wahrscheinlich wird es
aber nicht immer gelingen wenn sie jetzt
aufs nächste Jahr schauen was glauben
Sie wo wir landen werden
also dass die Zukunft ist immer offen
als Realismus muss man da so sagen ich
bin gegen
katastrophenpredigerei das hilft uns
auch nicht und Pessimismus hilft uns
auch nicht ich habe die Erfahrung
gemacht auch als Historiker und
politischer Wissenschaftler
das ist immer Alternativen gibt nehmen
Sie mal der erneuerbaren Energien mein
lieblings- und Lebensthema ist das
geworden die billigste Energie heute ist
Sonne und Wind dieses Chance aber in der
Kombination wir haben sechs erneuerbare
Energiequellen wir haben
Speichermöglichkeiten das ist ein großes
das ist sehr großes Thema ist mein
großes Thema wir könnten viel viel
weiter sein wenn in den letzten vier
Bundes vier Bundesregierungen der Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren forcierter
vorangetrieben auch da gibt es
Alternativen wir brauchen keine
Atomkraftwerke und wir brauchen keine
Atombomben und Politik vor dem
Hintergrund glauben sie dass in den
nächsten Monaten dieser Krieg enden wird
das wir alle gemeinsam und vor allen
Dingen diejenigen die das angezettelt
haben Ausweg finden wenn alle versuchen
im Sinne des großen Friedens Freundes
aus Nazaret dieses wunderbaren jungen
Mannes aus Nazareth
alles was in ihrer Macht stehen zu tun
haben wir die Chance
2023 ein zumindest zum Ende denke ich
ein Friedensjahr hinzukriegen aber da
muss mehr versucht werden da müssen auch
die eigenen Fehler deutlich angesprochen
werden mehr als bisher dann haben wir
wieder eine Chance das ist ein schönes
und ein optimistisches Schlusswort am
Ende dieses Talk Jahres hier auch bei
Bild ich hoffe die realistisch ganz ganz
viel gestritten haben heftig diskutiert
haben gegen sehr hoch her hier an diesem
Tisch und umso mehr gefällt mir dieses
ruhigere und besinnliche Schlusswort
danke Inhalt danke ihnen teilweise
[Musik]